[Music]
hello everybody
well yeah because you just sat there
going
you're just out there looking like that
all right today we uh
last night we saw blades of glory this
[ __ ] was like a ridiculous man it's
funny
this is one of the movies we just okay
so like last night was no need for me to
uh if he's here today i don't know thank
you again he's the guy that sent us this
awesome new laptop that we're streaming
on
he also sent us this massive stack of
movies
and uh so last night we watched you know
the movie that we were gonna do the
retrospective on so we could record that
and then i told tom i was like we'll
pick one of these
and we'll review it for the matinee show
tomorrow so he picked blades of glory
because we haven't seen a comedy in a
long time i like i like good comedies
yeah this is one of them this is a good
comedy and i have to say i'm not
usually a big will ferrell fan like i
liked um
elf that's everybody liked elf the [ __ ]
has to be [ __ ] silly though it's
gotta be really ridiculous and this this
humor was right up my ass yeah this one
was totally ridiculous and
so that made it awesome yeah i mean dude
i mean the premise
of it was like pretty ridiculous but
it's just so i i think it not so much
the premise of it but just like the over
the top they just went totally over the
top with it it just like committed
if you haven't seen this one it's what
if you haven't seen this one like and
what it's about
it's about competition ice skating i
guess they're professional ice skaters
it wasn't olympic it was professional
well you're not allowed to say olympic
in the movie
yeah you can't say copyright or whatever
right yeah so
it's about these two guys that do this
and they both got well
i don't want to spoil everything but
anyway
they try to make ice skating to be as
[ __ ]
macho as you possibly can [ __ ]
imagine all right and
well chas is character michaels
yeah chas michael's chas michael
michaels
that's the first guy and this
motherfucker's over the top [ __ ]
macho
you know what i mean it's just [ __ ]
he's a man after my whole heart if i'm
set on
eight that motherfucker's on 12. okay
it's [ __ ] hilarious all right
and his character you know
[Laughter]
his physique is [ __ ] very calm and
that's part of the joke but he he
doesn't really
see himself that way he's just kind of
dumpy
and then it's about this rival that he
has
in the skating industry was just what
was the name of that character
jimmy mcelroy jimmy mcelroy and jimmy
macro is exactly the opposite he's just
like this kind of [ __ ]
effeminate pretty boy and [ __ ] and
he's not gay he isn't he does like girls
but
other than that for all intents and
purposes he's like the gay character
well and he was the funny thing about it
is that he's an
orphan and then when he's little he gets
like plucked out of
the orphanage by this billionaire who
adopts orphans that have
athletic prowess and then he so he's
been like groomed
to be a figure skater like since he was
a little kid yeah
they make this [ __ ] funny as hell too
you know what i mean and um
they're in this big uh feud you know
and uh they end up winning the same gold
medal
in a [ __ ] dead tie and they start
fighting and that gets them kicked out
of professional skating they're not
allowed to come back in
years past they kind of become losers in
a way because you know they they can't
skate anymore
well some lawyers go back
through how they got banned and found
out no it wasn't a lawyer
it was jimmy's stalker it was a stalker
that's right that's right
that's what made it funny stalker that's
right i forgot about jimmy stalker
man this [ __ ] is [ __ ] funny he's
gonna kill you someday yeah
yeah now in the deleted scenes there's
more of that stalker
and there's a bunch more to the story
well there was a scene of him in the
credits i don't know if you saw that or
not
because he what happened was we watched
it and he fell asleep
at the last third but today he watched
it right yeah
and the deleted scenes are really good
too because it fleshes out a bunch of
stuff
about the meanings of the [ __ ]
tattoos remember the tattoo he said i
won't talk about that one well
they cut out the where that came from
they cut out a bunch of stuff that
really should have been left in there
there should be a re-edit of that so the
entire story's there so i didn't watch
the deleted scenes
yeah the deleted scenes have a lot more
okay okay that explain a lot of
backstory
um the uh [ __ ] what was i getting at
the uh oh okay
so anyway the stalker finds out that
they only got
banned from skating as singles yeah that
if they went out back and [ __ ]
and skated as a team as like a man-woman
pair they could get back in and uh so
they do that
and well i think well initially what
happens it's jimmy stalker
and jimmy stalker says well why don't
you just find a female partner you can
you know you can compete as pairs yeah
but he has
trouble finding a partner and it so ends
up that it's like
through some kind of like plot
contrivance or whatever yeah that him
and chaz end up
right well they were also they were they
were both pros and they were gonna like
break the stereotype that it had to be a
man and a woman
yeah because there was nothing in the
world it's just going to be be these two
dudes
okay just like there's and this [ __ ] is
awesome [ __ ] just gay
[ __ ] is [ __ ] hilarious he's trying to
make it as macho as he can and the more
macho he tries to make it
the gayer it comes across and it's
[ __ ] hilarious
and uh they start getting back and
skating and they have a new rival it's a
team it's a brother and sister team
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] hilarious too yeah
i like that whole thing
their parents died when they were young
so they kind of raised each other with
their
it was three of them but the it was the
two skaters and then like the little
sister
yeah okay because she's an important
character as it goes
as it goes on played by pam from those
yeah now the two
the two brother and sister teams you
know
they're obviously [ __ ] just into each
other you know yeah and they cut out
some stuff
and in the deleted scenes you know the
little s the little citrus like yeah
what do you guys know about dating all
you do is just you know
uh sleep with each other yeah yeah and
they were just like uh
they tried to [ __ ] but they're
obviously in this incestuous
relationship and it's just
they they riff on that through the whole
[ __ ] movie it's just [ __ ]
hilarious
everything about the movie is hilarious
um
and i love that i mean the brother in
that team is uh what's his face uh
will arnett i think it's his name from
uh arrested development and i love that
guy
it's not a laugh-a-minute movie it's a
constant laugh through the whole [ __ ]
movie
i thought it was really really fun
everything about the movie you know
what's interesting about it too
it's like and i think this is the reason
why elf worked as well and like i said
maybe some other will ferrell movies i
might enjoy them too i haven't seen a
lot of them
um you know i remember what was that one
that sherlock holmes when we saw that
not too long yeah it was like the worst
movie ever it wasn't funny but yeah that
was like
super super not funny they knew it
wasn't funny when they were making that
movie
they were breaking character they knew
that that [ __ ] wasn't funny there was
only one funny part and that's where
they [ __ ] beat up
beat up the queen mother and try to stop
yeah that was the price to try this
different thing
that was the only part that was funny
the rest of that [ __ ] was not funny it
was really not yeah everything
all the jokes kind of fell with the
clock and they were they knew that they
were all the chokes for bomb and you
could tell they're like
that's a bomb joke yeah you know it's
just funny
like i said now a lot of people said
anchorman is really funny which i really
need to see i haven't seen it yet
and talladega nights i think louis said
talladega nights was really funny
um which was kind of the same thing
where because that was also kind of like
a sports movie parody right
but i think the reason why this this was
good
is one not only is it like really funny
but also it's also kind of heartwarming
you know what i mean yeah the the the
the movie is about
brotherhood yes brotherhood and
friendship
yeah and and it is it is not a
mean-spirited movie
not at all and i think that's why i
liked it yeah i would put it up there
which which is kind of funny to have
good comedic taste and good and comedic
timing
as a comedian and performer you have to
be very mean
you got to have a dark side be cruel
that's where a lot of humor comes from
but it's not full it's masked you know
it's kind of like
passive aggression so it's kind of funny
how
it's kind of rare that a comedy movie is
is uh not mean-spirited
if you ask me well i don't know it
depends on what it i think there's like
i said there's a fine line between
i mean i don't know i tend to not like
really mean spirited comedy but it can
be done well
yeah you know what i'm saying i put this
one up there with two of my favorites
all right in terms of like quality level
i put it up there with tenacious d and i
would put it up there with nacho libre
which i love those two movies i think
they're [ __ ]
school of rock might be a little bit
better but i don't think school of rock
was
as funny actually as the and it's hard
to say i put it up there with nacho
libre
i really like nacho yeah nacho libre is
[ __ ] really good
and like i said i'm kind of like i don't
know i have like weird comedic taste you
know what i mean so i guess it's like so
it's
it's really hit or miss on whether a
comedy is gonna like be funny to me or
not
because for some reason like a lot of
stuff is just not funny to me for me the
benchmark is nacho libre
yeah i judge i judge everything based
upon but see i think that's another one
where
that's a movie where it's really funny
but it's not mean-spirited it's
it's actually kind of sweet yep but it's
still but the humor is still like funny
and kind of edgy
i guess and jack black playing he's
playing a uh
a mexican um priest he's a priest or
he's a he's a
fraud a bunker a bunker yeah he wants to
be
a luchador a luchadori
[ __ ] great and he wants to get the
girl and he does get the girl and
everything it's good good movie
i mean but the thing about okay so the
thing about blades of glory i really
like like i said i really love the
over-the-top premise i love
all the crazy costumes um
you know the first one like with jimmy's
first routine when he has that peacock
thing on
yeah oh my god that's amazing and i love
when they do their first
team skate and they're doing fire and
ice and they just like they're just like
these ridiculous i love the whole thing
about the iron lotus
yeah that movie like a special north
carolina one like the beheading
and said oh my god that was so [ __ ]
funny because i really really like like
uh kind of just ridiculous gore humor
like that
so they didn't kind of have that moment
in it where they're watching the video
and they're like
and like you know what i mean so coach
tells them they have to do that
like they keep taking the heads off and
everything [ __ ] that was so funny there
was a but there's a bunch of stuff in
there
i'll show you the deleted scenes later
on tonight the deleted scenes
uh flesh out a lot of stuff um
um i don't was that i don't remember if
that was in the deli
see because i'll watch the deleted
scenes right after i saw the beginning
of it so i'm getting kind of confused
about
what was in what and some of it is
expanded scenes like other takes of the
same scene
yeah where they said some funny [ __ ] it
wasn't exactly the same but it was
alternate funny [ __ ] right yeah that was
good they were evidently
ad-libbing a lot of this yeah
well a lot of them like i said a lot of
them have worked together before yeah
you know what i mean because they're
kind of like an ensemble
yeah and there's also like uh uh some
interviews with like the
the the the incestuous couple
yeah yeah well now they have that they
the one scene with them at the end where
they're getting arrested
yeah um they do like like make out
like for a second yeah you know what i
mean so they so that is like some of
that is in the movie
okay but you're so that was actually in
the movie because i remember laughing
with that part but i think they were
sleeping
yeah she slaps him and then all of a
sudden they [ __ ] yeah like a
love-hate
relationship and they finally [ __ ]
they finally let it out of the bag that
they're [ __ ]
another thing which is obvious from all
their [ __ ] promotional materials like
you're on the covers and her legs
wrapped around him
kissing at the camera like yeah i'm
getting this
that kind of reminds me of [ __ ] who
is that [ __ ] who is that [ __ ]
actress that showed up to the damn
[ __ ]
oscars with her boyfriend and [ __ ]
tongue kissed her but
tom kissed her own [ __ ] brother was that
angel angelina jolie
i don't know if that was a stunt or what
probably might have been a stop no i
guess it wasn't
because she's because people are still
talking about well you're still talking
about yeah
i just remember when it happened that
was the closest thing she was i forgot
it was angelina jolie though yeah she's
[ __ ] crazy
was it a stunt though there were some
other people who thought they did know
that it wasn't a stunt
that she was sick and obsessed with her
brother for a while
[ __ ] crazy okay well i know i know that
but it still might have been a stunt it
might have been regardless
just because you know publicity yeah
that's some weird [ __ ] it's it's
yeah even in this day and age like uh
smooching your brother
yeah at a big global event i mean yeah
that's that's going to get some
attention
yeah that's ancient rome
that's ancient rome action right there
so yeah i did i did like that whole like
incest thing plus they were just
horrible people too like because they
were just i mean they would like
sabotage people yeah another thing i
really liked about this too
is that they had a lot of real uh figure
skaters
and a lot of like uh brian boytano was
in there nancy kerrigan was in there
um you know they played like kind of
judges at the whatever like when the
when they were getting kicked out so i
guess like they got a
the ice skating world got kind of uh you
know
i guess i guess they weren't too mad
about getting made fun of because a lot
of them like turned up in this
and a lot of the tattoos that will
ferrell's character had
uh he said that he'd slept with a bunch
of famous skaters like michelle kwan and
stuff like that and that's what he had
got the tattoo to like commemorate it
because he was a sex addict
yeah and that was like funny too like
the whole meeting that he went to and
all that other kind of crap
but yeah so like i said i haven't seen a
lot of will ferrell movies and they're
kind of hit or miss for me but actually
this one was actually really
entertaining i was i was really
entertained i thought it was really
funny
and i i mean yeah and i always really
liked ice skating anyway so it's like
the fact that they were kind of
parodying it
was uh was pretty amazing like i said
i'm gonna just
all i can say is i recommend it i put it
up there with with some of my favorites
which would be like nacho libre
and tenacious d
which you know some people don't like
jack black i like jack black's comedies
i like jack black too yeah um he was
pretty good in that
uh what was that movie it wasn't a
comedy it was like uh
house of the clock as well yeah yeah
yeah it was a pretty good one
you know what and we did a matinee on
that back when we were still doing the
matinees at the theater
i was so excited because if you guys if
anybody's gone back and read like some
of my really old blog posts
that was one of my favorite books as a
kid
uh the house with the clock and his
walls by john bel-airs good movie and i
was like super super excited
because a long time ago i was like why
has nobody made this into a [ __ ]
movie it would be amazing
um you know because the book is so
[ __ ] good and then they finally
finally did
and i really really liked the way it
came out book i liked when i was a kid
that they still haven't made a movie
about it it was
i think it might have been three of the
three of the books but i only really
remember the first one was called
day of the nest you ever heard of that
i don't think so some some little kids
were out playing and they found out
that some of these rocks had little
eyeballs and little [ __ ] antennas
that would come up out of them
when it turned out if you lift them up
and they
[ __ ] burrow underneath the ground
turned out they were aliens living
underneath the earth and they were
planning on coming back out and uh
conquering the [ __ ] planet and it was
more than one of them
different they had like flying bird
looking things and
human tarantula looking things and then
some of them looked like a damn rock
that had antennas and little hands that
came out
yeah i haven't seen a long time but that
would make a cool movie based on what i
remembered of it
that sounds like a good premise yeah and
it was little kids trying to stop
the debt the adults wouldn't believe
yeah little kids trying to stop the
alien invasion they were underneath the
ground i don't remember if they were
aliens
that had been living underneath there if
there were another species i think they
might have been aliens that had been
living down there for a while i'd watch
that
yeah well the thing about it i this is
why i wondered i'm glad they finally got
around to making the house with the
clock in his walls because like i said
that was easily my favorite book from
childhood
um but i would have thought especially
after harry potter came out and like all
this you know
that percy jackson and all those kind of
like y a kind of so like because why a
fiction just went [ __ ] bonkers
after harry potter came out and they you
know they wanted to make
so many movies they were looking for
like new franchises and stuff
and i'm like surprised they didn't i
don't know there was a lot of really
good [ __ ] that came out back then that
they never
like made i would have also loved to see
a movie of
uh the headless cupid by zilpha keatley
snyder
that was also another one of my favorite
books that wasn't a franchise though as
far as i remember she wrote a [ __ ] ton
of books but i think that was like
oh yeah okay yeah i don't think i read
that one
interesting i'm trying to get it to
focus yeah
it doesn't want to it's like oh it's so
hard
[Laughter]
it's so hard yeah that was a great book
for kids stopping the alien invasion
the damn aliens [ __ ] subterranean
aliens god damn it yep yeah i would have
liked to seen uh
yeah that would have been good the
headless cupid would have been good uh
what's that other [ __ ] book that i
really liked when i was a kid
god damn it was one called the witch's
egg that i really like that's what they
look like
oh okay i got you some of them look like
that kind of looks familiar
maybe i did read it
oh another one that would have been a
great [ __ ] uh
a great [ __ ] uh movie would have been
uh
the westing game ellen raskin wrote that
that was more like a mystery
but that was still like really really
good i'm surprised they never made a
movie of that why didn't they make a
movie of that
that book was like [ __ ] so that's
there
yeah yeah that book was like a huge
success like back in the day and it like
won the newbery medal and all that [ __ ]
so i don't know why they didn't like all
ellen raskin's books were good actually
like figs and phantoms and stuff but the
westing game was my favorite
i don't know why they never made that
into a movie or maybe they did and i
just didn't see it who knows
but uh yeah so are you done that's it
man yeah we haven't like uh been
streaming that long but oh well what are
you gonna do doesn't matter we got done
it's our show yeah i gotta go and uh
edit the yeah
other thing and we uh yeah i was gonna
say you're gonna say something yeah
we uh did a shirt who was this shirt for
that was for
blaster one yeah blaster one i know what
your real name did his shirt
that's our tyrell shirt yeah we made the
tyrell one today
i'm gonna pop that in the mail tomorrow
yeah that's from blade runner
yep got it all
yeah i gotta go i was gonna go to the
post office today but it's storming like
hell outside
so i don't really want to go out in it
but you know what i mean
all right so we will be back tomorrow
for talking about another movie we'll
either we'll either watch another one
from that pile
or uh i haven't been keeping up with all
the new [ __ ] on shutters and maybe i'll
go watch
like find something new on shutter and
watch that i don't know i'll figure it
out whatever mood i'm in later today
louie says she kissed him on the lips
louie man she [ __ ] [ __ ] tongue
kissed him that was a french kiss dude
if i remember correctly that was a i'm
sure that video is out there
that's super weird i i have brothers and
that's like a super weird thing to think
about
and they just flowers in the attic and
they were like dressing alike and
everything they were both kind of
gotheed out and [ __ ]
and it just yeah i kind of remember that
it just look it just looked like you
know
man of moon pie yeah
now i'm kind of wishing that i had like
bought some snacks because i didn't buy
anything
this is nutritious man it's not
nutritious
i was yeah because we went in the other
day well we were gonna get a mcdonald's
for lunch but it was too [ __ ] crowded
so we went to [ __ ] hardy's you know
not ideal but uh at least there was
nobody in there but the hardy's by our
house is in the back of a convenience
store
okay there's a circle okay and while we
were in the circle k
he was all excited and he was like ooh
look nana boom pies and he bought a
couple of them and like some other [ __ ]
like you buy
cheese puffs or something like a
cheeseburger but what about um but he
bought up like a bunch of snacks
and i was kind of in there and they had
some of those um
those pies you know that have like the
the pie but then they have like the
pudding inside like chocolate and then
yes they weren't hostess though i think
they were the circle k
brand yeah and i was just kind of like
oh man i just i used to love those when
i was
little like the dolly matt what are they
dolly madison that was like [ __ ]
dolly madison yeah snoopy was on it i
think
that's right it had peanuts characters
and that was dolly madison i'm pretty
sure they came in a paper
in a wax paper yeah it's like a wax
paper yeah i still like the chocolate
ones and the lemon ones
they don't come in bags anymore they
come in a box yeah it's like a little
box just like the
just like the cherry pie or whatever
that at mcdonald's they come in that
like [ __ ] box
i was like now i'm kind of wishing that
i bought some of those oh well they're
good if you heat them up
yeah i know but i don't you know i don't
have anything to snack on this afternoon
i'm gonna have to like rustle something
up
maybe i'll just eat some toast or
something with sediment on it whatever i
have my nutrition for today
all that protein that's all this
nutrient
banana bowl pie uh louis says watch gone
baby gone good mystery movie guys
i was just watching a video earlier
today uh that was like a list of
what was it best twists or something
like that and that was one of the ones
that was on there
i still haven't seen it i'll get around
to it one of these days there's so many
[ __ ] movies i gotta say that i'm
so behind and tv shows as well all right
so
uh we will be back tomorrow talking
about another movie we'll find out what
it is
uh later we'll see what mood we're in
tom's gonna finish his native moon pie
that's nice
he can't talk right now he's got a
mouthful he's too busy enjoying the
moonpie goodness
all right we will see you guys again
tomorrow
bye